les leaders politiques
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'hebdo
politique votre rendez vous du dimanche
soir sur radio sensations en association
avec tv sur 18 épisodes de 218 mon
invité ce soir et la climatologue
françoise vimeu
[Musique]
l'hebdo politique
françoise villemont bonsoir vous êtes
climatologue à l'ird et l'institut de
recherche pour le développement et
directrice de recherche au laboratoire
des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement au plateau de saclay est
également vous travaillez au labo
hydrosciences à montpellier alors voilà
pour la présentation le laboratoire
sciences du climat et de l'environnement
lsce
c'est donc au plateau de saclay jeu les
17 unités mixtes de recherche cea cnrs
et l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines il a été créé en 1998 alors
concrètement si vous pouvez nous
présenter ce laboratoire quelles sont
ces travaux oui alors c'est un
laboratoire de 300 personnes environ qui
travaille à la fois sur le climat et
l'environnement et sur la partie climat
on travaille beaucoup à comprendre
comment le climat a évolué à varier dans
le passé et aussi comment le climat
évolue aujourd'hui et dans le futur et
c'est un laboratoire qui en fait utilise
pour faire simple deux approches une
approche basée sur les observations que
l'on collecte sur le terrain et puis une
approche de modélisation à la fois des
climats passés et des climats futur ans
vous étudiez la variabilité l'évolution
du climat vous l'avez dit vous êtes donc
une spécialiste du changement climatique
d'ailleurs on attend aussi l'expression
dérèglement climatique ou réchauffement
climatique quelle est la bonne
expression là celle qui a le plus de
sens propre alors il la bonne expression
je dirais c'est certainement changement
climatique le mot changement il inclut
le mot des règlements le mot
réchauffement est un peu réducteur parce
que en fait lorsque le climat change il
n'y a pas que la température qui se
modifie il ya la température et puis ça
a un impact sur un ensemble de variables
météorologiques donc changement
climatique c'est un bon terme en quoi
consiste votre travail de climatologues
au quotidien sur quels sujets travaillez
vous alors moi j'ai beaucoup travaillé à
comprendre comment le climat a varié
dans le passé en particulier dans les
régions autres pical et depuis quelques
années je travaille toujours sur les
régions tropicales mais je m'intéresse
davantage à comprendre des processus
atmosphériques qu'on connaît mal et qui
sont reliés aux pluies par exemple sur
les cyclones sur les pluies de mousson
ou encore sur les nuages d'orage qui
semble des choses très simples mais en
fait il ya encore plein de processus
qu'on connaît mal qu'on représente mal
et donc on a un peu de difficulté à
savoir comment ces processus vont
évoluer dans un climat différent un
climat plus chaud dans le mois dernier
siècle le groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat a publié un nouveau rapport sur
la situation de notre planète alors
avant de rentrer dans le détail avec
vous j'aimerais d'abord qu'on parle de
cet organisme qui a été créée en 1988
alors à quoi sert-il le giec et qui le
composent alors le giec donc si vous
l'avez dit c'est le groupe
intergouvernemental d'experts sur le
climat c'est en fait un groupe qui
travaille sous la houlette de
l'organisation des nations unies et le
giec va répondre en fait à des commandes
des gouvernements qui veulent savoir
quel est l'état de nos connaissances sur
le changement climatique et qui sont
demandeurs d'avoir aussi des stratégies
d'adaptation et d'atténuation et donc le
giec est constitué de plusieurs
centaines de scientifiques qui vont
candidaté en tout les 4 à 6 ans
lorsqu'il ya des nouveaux rapports pour
participer en fait à ces travaux est ce
qu'il faut rappeler c'est que le giec et
séparés en trois groupes donc le premier
groupe il va travailler sur les bases
physiques du climat vraiment à
comprendre ce qui se passe en termes de
changements climatiques le deuxième
groupe qui a sorti son rapport il ya un
mois comme vous le disiez lui va
travailler sur les impacts du changement
climatique la vulnérabilité est
l'adaptation et puis le troisième groupe
dont le rapport va sortir début avril va
travailler sur ce qu'on appelle la
mitigation c'est-à-dire l'atténuation du
changement climatique comme on atténue
en fait ce réchauffement les trois
groupes sanction des spécialités de
chacun alors dans chacun des groupes
vous avez plus de 200 scientifiques et
ce qu'il faut rappeler c'est que ces 6
anti fiq dans le cadre du giec ne font
pas de recherche par eux-mêmes ils vont
faire la synthèse des travaux qui ont
été publiées sur les dernières années et
donc ils vont apporter l'état des
connaissances et puis ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que lorsqu'ils vont
faire cette synthèse ils vont aussi
faire une analyse de ce que l'on sait
très bien de ce que l'on sait bien
moyennement et pas du tout et d'ailleurs
dans le giec dans les rapports du giec
il ya toujours des niveaux de confiance
qui sont associés à bien à des
affirmations à des assertions par
exemple dans le volet 1 qui est parue
l'été dernier il y à un niveau de
confiance de 100% sur le fait que le
changement climatique que l'on vit
depuis la fin du 19e siècle est dû aux
activités humaines pour ce nouveau
rapport dont on parle actuellement donc
c'est la partie du sixième rapport du
giec des rapports d'évaluation alors il
a si l'uci rapports déjà à chaque
rapport qu'elle est le la nouveauté des
avancées des études mises à jour une
sorte de mise à jour des connaissances
alors en fait tous les 4 à 6 ans lie à
un nouveau rapport est bien sûr les
recherches évolue donc il y a des
nouvelles connaissances il y à des
précisions qui sont apportées il y a des
aspects qu'on connaissait très mal il ya
30 ans 20 ans et qu'aujourd'hui on
connaît beaucoup mieux il ya aussi la
volonté en termes de projections
climatiques d'aller vers la ce qu'on
appelle la régionalisation c'est à dire
regardez plus en détail sur les
territoires comment la température
comment les pluies vont varier et il ya
aussi une amélioration des modèles pour
réaliser ces projections climatiques
donc oui il ya des nouvelles
connaissances ya des nouvelles
précisions si on prend le volet 1 par
exemple de l'été dernier il ya eu un
nouveau chapitre sur les événements
extrêmes on a énormément progressé sur
la connaissance de ces événements
extrêmes et surtout sur leurs
attributions ou pas au changement
climatique alors quand on pense aux
changements climatiques justement on
pense surtout aux femmes et émissions de
gaz à effet de serre alors commence et
ses émissions ont-elles un impact sur la
planète alors en fait c'est un phénomène
assez simple que l'on connaît depuis
longtemps plus vous mettez de gaz à
effet de serre comme le dioxyde de
carbone ou comme le méthane dans
l'atmosphère est plus en fait votre
atmosphère est capable de conserver la
chaleur qui est émise par la surface de
la terre ça agit en quelque sorte un
petit peu commune ouverture et donc on
va réchauffer les basses couches de
l'atmosphère soit mais il faut savoir
que cet effet de serre c'est un
processus naturel s'il n'y avait pas de
gaz à effet de serre dans l'atmosphère
de manière naturelle il faudrait
vraiment très froid à la surface de
notre planète aux alentours de -18
degrés le fait qu'il y a un effet de
serre naturel ça permet d'avoir une
température moyenne à la surface de la
terre de 15 degrés mais ce qu'on est en
train de faire c'est qu'on est en train
de rajouter des gaz à effet de serre par
les activités humaines et donc
automatiquement au n'augmente la
température moyenne de notre planète
donc en 2021 cette température était a
augmenté déjà de +1 1 degrés par rapport
à l'ère préindustrielle alors les
accords de paris ont fixé un objectif de
ne pas dépasser les plus à 25° pourquoi
ce chiffre pourquoi ce alors deux choses
le chiffre de 1,1 degré c'est une
anomalie de température sur les dix
dernières années un pas seulement 2021
par rapport à la deuxième moitié du 19e
siècle donc mille huit cent cinquante
mille neuf cent ans 8 le chiffre de 1,5
degré il a été déterminé lors des
accords de paris en 2015
l'idée était de savoir quel est le degré
de réchauffement acceptable et il y a eu
à l'époque beaucoup de discussions entre
1,5 et 2 degrés est en fait ce sont les
les états insulaires qui sont
particulièrement vulnérables à la montée
du niveau des mers qui ont demandé à ce
que on travaille sur quels seraient les
scénarios d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre à suivre pour ne pas dépasser 1,5
degré et donc la barre a été mis à 1,5
et non pas à deux degrés alors ce
rapport dont on parle c'est le groupe de
travail 2 qui l'a rédigé celui qui
s'intéresse donc aux impacts du
changement climatique ainsi qu aux
enjeux d'adaptation et de vulnérabilité
alors selon ce rapport entre 3 3 et 3 6
milliards de personnes vivent dans un
contexte de forte vulnérabilité au
changement climatique alors ça
représente presque un humain sur sur
deux quels sont les messages forts que
vous avez retenu de ce rapport alors de
de ce volet ii il ya plusieurs messages
forts le premier message c'est de
rappeler que le changement climatique il
a déjà aujourd'hui des impacts et que
ses impacts il se généralise et il
s'intensifie si bien que d'ici quelques
années à quelques décennies n'y aura
plus aucun territoire à la surface du
globe qui sera épargné par les impacts
du changement climatique
ensuite le second message fort je pense
qu'on rentrera dans les détails après
mais c'est de dire que l'adaptation
aujourd'hui au changement climatique
elle est nécessaire elle existe mais
elle n'est pas suffisante face à la
rapidité du changement climatique et
puis aussi cette adaptation elle a des
limites elle est difficile elle devient
très complexe au delà d'un réchauffement
de 1,5 ou 2 degrés sachant
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes sur des
trajectoires d'émissions de gaz à effet
de serre qui nous emmène à environ + 3
degrés à la fin du siècle et puis je
crois qu'il ya des notions importantes
dans ce rapport
qui dit que les impacts du changement
climatique c'est à la fois sur les
sociétés humaines mais sur les
écosystèmes aussi que l'adaptation elle
peut avoir d'écho bénéfices à la fois en
termes d'adaptation au changement
climatique mais en terme d'équité et de
justice sociale et puis ce rapport fait
aussi
un jeu dire un constat assez affligeant
sur ce qu'on appelle la malle adaptation
c'est à dire que des fois on va mettre
en place des adaptations qui vont
s'avérer efficace sur le très court
terme mais qui vont s'avérer une
catastrophe sur le long terme alors donc
premier point du rapport dont il compare
différents continents quelles sont les
zones géographiques donc les plus
vulnérables qui sont les plus en danger
selon ce rapport oui alors dans ce
rapport il ya ce qu'on appelle des
hotspots c'est vraiment des régions
particulièrement vulnérable même si
toutes les régions vont être vulnérable
à un moment donné on parle de la région
de la méditerranée
qui est soumise et qui va être soumise à
des événements extrêmes comme les vagues
de chaleur les sécheresses ou même les
pluies diluviennes on le voit sur notre
territoire avec ces événements
méditerranéen qui apporte des pluies
diluviennes sur le sud de la france on
parle de l'article
parce que on sait que le réchauffement
climatique
est accentuée sur les hautes latitudes
de l'hémisphère nord et puis on parle
après de certaines régions de l'amérique
du sud comme le bassin amazonien
certaines régions sur le continent
africain et certaines régions en asie
oui parler des îles insulaire recyclé
oui clairement oui oui particulièrement
vulnérables les petites îles est ce qu
on appelle les zones de basse altitude
avec une altitude inférieure à 10 mètres
qui sont particulièrement vulnérables à
la montée du niveau des mers on peut
rappeler qu'aujourd'hui en moyenne
l'augmentation du niveau de la mer c'est
20 cm et on a des fourchettes pour les
projections qui vont de 40 cm à 1 m et
donc là c'est vraiment des choses très
compliquées à gérer on va parler des
zones les plus vulnérables mais pour les
autres les zones qui sont un peu moins
vulnérables justement est-ce qu'elle
soit veut dire que ces zones sont déjà
tirés d'affaires pas du tout alors pas
du tout en fait
il n'y a pas vraiment de zone tiré
d'affaires je vais vous donner un
exemple il y a un territoire très commun
qui a été planté dans ce rapport comme
étant particulièrement vulnérables c'est
les villes et les villes vous en avait
partout sachant que à partir de 2050 on
estime qu'il y aura deux tiers de la
population qui vivra dans des villes où
on voit ces séries ou à 2050 et ces
territoires sont vulnérables aux vagues
de chaleur aux inondations parce que
c'est complètement bétonné des vagues de
chaleur parce que évidemment vous avez
les faits îlots de chaleur qui est dû au
fait que vous avez des bâtiments qui
absorbent la chaleur et puis qui ensuite
la rejette et donc moi je dirais qu'il
n'y a pas de territoire qui sont sortis
d'affaires au contraire les événements
extrêmes canicules tempêtes son ami
éruptions volcaniques ou encore
inondations sont ils vraiment plus
fréquent quand ses derniers moments
alors que ton parle d'événements
extrêmes en termes de climat on va
parler de vague de chaleur de sécheresse
et de pluies diluviennes alors oui en
fait on sait que avec un océans plus
chauds et une atmosphère plus chaude on
vient exacerber ces événements extrêmes
à la fois en termes d'intensité en
termes de fréquence et par exemple pour
les vagues de chaleur en terme de durée
et on pense aussi que ces vagues de
chaleur elle pourrait être beaucoup plus
précoce au bout beaucoup plus tardive
d'ailleurs on en a eu un exemple en 2019
en france avec la canicule de juin voilà
donc oui ces événements extrêmes vont
être beaucoup plus fréquent beaucoup
plus intense et on s'attend aussi à
avoir ce qu'on appelle des événements
extrêmes composite c'est-à-dire des
événements extrêmes type vague de
chaleur et sécheresse qui vont arriver
en mai tant et dont les conséquences
vont être difficiles à gérer comment
est-ce que vous travaillez vous sur ces
événements alors personnellement je
travaille pas sur les événements
extrêmes et mes collègues qui le font en
fait vont se pose beaucoup la question
aujourd'hui de lorsqu'un événement
extrême arrive est-ce qu'on peut
l'attribuer aux changements climatiques
est ce que le changement climatique
expliquent cette pluie diluvienne et
donc en fait on regarde si cet événement
extrême aurait pu arriver dans un climat
non modifiées et donc on prend
exactement les mêmes conditions voilà
météorologiques et puis on demande aux
modèles voilà j'ai un climat non
modifiées par l'homme là j'ai un climat
modifié par l'homme est-ce que cet
événement extrême arrive et si oui est
ce qu'il aurait été aussi intense ans le
deuxième message fort de ce rapport
selon lui le changement climatique
affecte à la fois les sociétés humaines
et les écosystèmes alors d'avoir ce que
vous pouvez nous rappeler qu est ce qu
un écosystème alors un écosystème pour
faire simple c'est l'ensemble qui est
constituée par des êtres vivants faune
et flore et
l'environnement donc vous avez des
écosystèmes océaniques vous avez des
écosystèmes côtiers des écosystèmes
terrestres pour les écosystèmes
terrestres on parle par exemple des
forêts ou des zones montagneuses en jeu
précise que selon donc ce rapport
l'augmentation de dollars aura un impact
sur l'extinction d'espèces si on ne
dépasse pas les 5 degrés entre 9 et 14 %
des espèces seront impactés au dessus de
2 degrés ce sera entre 10 et 18 % des
espèces et si l'on atteint les 3 degrés
alors là ça pourrait être jusqu'à 29 %
des espèces les sociétés humaines seront
elles aussi impactés qu'elles sont déjà
les signes qui le montre au quotidien je
voudrais revenir sur la perte de
biodiversité
là ce que vous donner c'est des chiffres
moyens on voit effectivement que la
perte de biodiversité à l'augmentation
le degré de réchauffement on a déjà
aujourd'hui des régions qui sont
particulièrement vulnérables en termes
de perte de biodiversité c'est le bassin
amazonien c'est l'afrique équatoriale le
sud de l'afrique c'est aussi la sibérie
et puis par exemple le centre de
l'australie et on voit que lorsque l'on
va à un degré de réchauffement de 3
degrés 1 qui correspond aux trajectoires
sur lesquels nous sommes aujourd'hui eh
bien on a des pertes de biodiversité qui
sont au-delà de 75% et je peux aussi
donner un exemple qui est très frappant
pour moi dans un monde 2° vous avez 99 %
des récifs coralliens qui ont disparu
voilà donc ça c'est vraiment des images
très fortes et puis pour revenir à votre
question sur les sociétés humaines eh
bien on voit déjà aujourd'hui des
impacts alors qu'ils sont divers ça peut
être sur la ressource et la
disponibilité en eau ça peut être sur la
sécurité alimentaire ça peut être tout
simplement sur la santé ça peut être sûr
des choses peut être plus légère mais
pas forcément le tourisme et puis bien
sûr sur sur l'économie et les emplois
pour évoquer des chiffres de ce rapport
pour vous parler de sécurité alimentaire
selon le rapport lui pour cent des
terres agricoles ne seront plus
cultivables d'ici 2100 avec
l'augmentation de plus de 1,5 degré et
comme on ne sait pas encore comment
évoluera la démographie mondiale sera ça
pourra sûrement poser des problèmes pour
nourrir plus de personnes avec moins de
terres cultivables c'est l'une des
conséquences vous avez parlé de des
conséquences notamment dans le domaine
de la santé aussi selon le rapport la
france soit menacée avec près de 4000
morts par an dus à cause des vagues de
chaleur et la montée de la mer enfin
aussi pourrait impacter un milliard de
personnes vivent sur les zones côtières
ce sont des zones où le monde sur le
groupe de plus en plus oui alors en fait
on sait que la population sur les
littoraux va augmenter d'à peu près 10
15 % d'ici 2050 ce qui pose
effectivement ce problème de ces régions
côtières qui sont très vulnérables alors
d'abord tout simplement parce que la mer
monte donc finalement elle gagne du
territoire parce qu'il ya un effet
finalement de 7 2 comment dire
salinisation des eaux qui rentre et puis
c'est des zones qui deviennent très
vulnérables aux tempêtes à cause des
submersions marines alors qu'est ce qui
se passe c'est ce qu'on a vu en france
lors de la tempête xynthia en 2010 vous
avez une tempête vous avez une
dépression il ya un petit effet
d'aspiration du niveau de la mer et donc
une submersion marine et on comprend
bien que c'est au niveau de la mer et
plus élevée dans 50 ans eh ben pour une
tempête beaucoup plus petit coq cynthia
vous allez arriver à la même catastrophe
et à la même submersion marine on s'est
vraiment des zones très très vulnérable
alors troisième donc dernier message
fort les efforts d'adaptation donc le
giec les reconnaît mené dans toutes les
régions mais affirme qu'il faut aller
encore plus loin et que les décisions
prises à court terme auront un impact
décisif sur les années à venir alors où
est ce qu'on a emmené dans les efforts
d'adaptation aujourd'hui oui le constat
majeur de ce rapport il est très sévère
sur l'adaptation il dit que l'adaptation
existe aujourd'hui dans tous les
secteurs et tous les territoires mais
que c'est une adaptation qui est trop
lente qui est pas à la hauteur de la
rapidité du changement climatique qui
reste au niveau local qui est très
fragmentée 1 c c'est souvent des
initiatives locales mais ya pas une
organisation sur la grande échelle et
puis ce rapport vient pointer que la
plupart des adaptations aujourd'hui sont
réalisés pour le court terme et qu'elles
ne seront pas valables à long terme
alors je peux vous donner un exemple
aujourd'hui dans les constructions il ya
la notion de bien-être estivale c'est à
dire comment être chez soi sans trop
souffrir lorsqu'il y aura des vagues de
chaleur et la référence qui est prise
pour les vagues de chaleur c'est la
canicule de 2003 or la canicule de 2003
enfin l'été 2003 ça nous apparaîtra
comme un été normal au milieu du siècle
donc on se trompe de référence il
faudrait prendre des références beaucoup
plus élevés pour voilà pour que ce soit
finalement une adaptation sur le long
terme et puis il ya aussi la lamal
adaptation à on voit par exemple
penser que sur les petites îles dont on
a parlé pour se protéger de l'élévation
du niveau des mers on a envie de
construire des digues c'est une très
mauvaise idée parce qu'en fait les ils
ont la capacité naturellement aa gagné
du territoire sur la mer par transfert
et dépôts de sédiments lorsqu'il ya par
exemple des cyclones et dès que vous
mettez une d'idées bien vous empêchez
finalement cette reconstruction naturel
donc ce que dit ce rapport c'est que
faut vraiment faire attention à la malle
adaptation est d'ailleurs ce rapport
donne des décès des bonnes entre
guillemets solution et se présente comme
un peu une feuille de route pour les
décideurs pour ses aspects d'adaptation
quelles peuvent être les limites à
l'adaptation les limites économiques les
limites de la volonté politique alors il
ya évidemment des des limites
financières l'adaptation ça a un coût
il y a des limites politiques c'est plus
des apps l'absence de volonté politique
quelquefois on voit par exemple en
australie qui est quand même un
territoire soumis à énormément
d'événements extrêmes il ya quand même
un manque de volonté politique
on peut aussi avoir des fois un frein
qui est juste duo ressenti par exemple
en europe on a on n'a pas forcément à
ressentir d'urgence pour s'adapter au
changement climatique
donc voilà il ya plusieurs freins qui
sont possibles le rapport met aussi en
avant la notion de développement
résilient oui alors le développement
résignant ca signifie que lorsque l'on
va j'ai donné des exemples parce que
c'est un peu abstrait mais que lorsque
l'on va faire un développement il faut
vraiment le penser dans un cadre large
dans le cadre du changement climatique
donc par exemple lorsque l'on pense à
l'entretien des forêts et bien on peut
se dire voilà je suis sur un territoire
où finalement la disponibilité en eau va
diminuer au cours des années des
décennies à venir peut-être que je peux
réfléchir à penser d'autres à planter
pardon d'autres types d'arbres ça vaut
aussi pour les semences et les cultures
quels types de semences quel type de
culture je peux
auquel je peux penser qu'elle va être
l'irrigation nécessaire et regarder
finalement est ce que la région va
souffrir finalement de disponibilité en
eau donc il ya vraiment c'est cette idée
que le développement doit se faire de
manière pensée et éventuellement avec
des vins dans l'idéal pas éventuellement
mais avec deco bénéfices à la fois pour
les populations et pour les écosystèmes
alors le giec ne donne pas de directives
multiples direct l'objectif c'est d'être
une feuille de route pour les décideurs
vous comment est ce que vous voyez ce
rapport c'est c'est comme une feuille de
route c'est comme danser c'est
exactement ça le giec
ne donne pas de recommandations il m'est
vraiment sur la table et pour chacun de
ces trois volets un l'état des
connaissances dans le volet de à la
demande des gouvernements il y à des
stratégies d'adaptation qui sont
proposés selon les secteurs et selon les
territoires et il doit vraiment être lue
comme une feuille de route les décideurs
doivent s'en emparer et puis ça doit
aussi être discutée dans la société un
bien sûr ça ne signe pas le le
scientifique qui doit dire ce que l'on
doit faire bien sûr mais lui doit mettre
sur la table et à des connaissances
alors la guerre en ukraine a un peu
éclipsé médiatiquement ce la sortie de
ce rapport à ce que vous le comprenez où
est ce que vous êtes quand même déçu de
du de l'intérêt médiatique donnée à ce
rapport
or je crois que il n'ya pas que la
guerre en ukraine moi j'ai été
signataires d'une tribune
bien avant quelques semaines avant qui a
été signé par 1400 de mes collègues
aussi où on alerté les médias sur le
fait qu'il n'y avait pas assez de
questions posées aux candidats à la
présidentielle sur les aspects du
changement climatique parce que on pense
que le changement climatique c'est un
sujet éminemment politique parce qu'on
l'a dit ça touche la santé ça touche
l'économie ça touche la sécurité des
personnes lorsque vous avez des pluies
diluviennes il faut assurer la sécurité
des personnes et les extraire de ces
territoires et donc c'est vraiment le
moment voilà de discuter en se basant
par exemple sur le rapport 2-2 de verre
où on va voir où on souhaite aller et
comment on souhaite s'adapter
voilà la question que tout le monde
s'est passé ce qu'il est déjà trop tard
pour agir ou alors il est absolument pas
trop tard mais il faut agir maintenant
alors on sait que là le changement du
climat bon le système thématiques à une
certaine inertie donc le changement de
notre climat sur les décennies à venir
et jusqu'à à peu près 2040 2050 et écrit
par ce que nous avons déjà rejeté dans
l'atmosphère sur les dernières décennies
par contre nous avons complètement le
choix du type de changements climatiques
du degré de réchauffement que nous
aurons à partir de la deuxième partie du
21e siècle et la coop 26 l'a bien montré
si on réduit
dès maintenant de manière drastique nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone en 2050
on peut encore être sur des trajectoires
où on va dépasser 1,5 degré mais on va
rester en dessous de deux degrés dont on
a encore la maîtrise et la possibilité
vraiment de stabiliser en fait ce
réchauffement il ya régulièrement des
manifestations des marches pour le
climat qui sont organisées ce que vous
avez le sentiment que la prise de
conscience est en train de se faire ou
donc c'est encore assez assez limité
alors mon ressenti personnel et qu'il ya
vraiment eu une prise de conscience au
niveau individuel en particulier chez
les jeunes dont le changement climatique
est vraiment une préoccupation après il
ya peut-être soit un gap enfin un saut
entre la prise de conscience et puis
l'action que l'on peut faire sachant
qu'en fait on sait très bien que au
niveau individuel on peut agir sur la
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre mais c'est limité à 25 30 %
après doit y avoir des décisions
politiques par exemple vous ne
choisissez pas quel est votre mix
énergétique voilà vous il vous est
imposée mais par contre vous pouvez
décider qu'à l'avenir vous aimeriez
qu'on vous propose des plans un peu
différent qui vous aimeriez pouvoir
choisir donc le troisième volet du
rapport est attendu en avril pour donc
on devrait y voir des solutions pour
réduire des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre qu'est ce que vous attendez de ce
rapport alors pardon oui le troisième
rapport va être disponibles 4 avril donc
c'est un rapport qui est entièrement
dédiée à l'atténuation du changement
climatique
sachant que adaptation et atténuation
doivent être menées en parallèle on doit
à la fois s'adapter parce qu'on sait que
le changement climatique est en marche
et on doit à la fois essayer d'atténuer
pour ne pas aller vers des degrés de
réchauffement qui serait très
difficilement gérable 1 le volet 2 du
rapport dit clairement que l'adaptation
devient vraiment complexe au delà de 1,5
et 2 degrés est donc ce que ce que ce
que ce que l'on attend enfin ce que les
décideurs doivent doivent attendre de ce
rapport c'est aussi encore une feuille
de route sur quelles sont les
différentes possibilités suivant les
territoires pour atténuer ce changement
climatique rendez vous donc le 4 avril
pour voir les dessine ce rapport merci
beaucoup françoise buffet d'avoir été
avec nous s'appelle que vous êtes
climatologues donc à l'ird et l'institut
de recherche au développement et donc
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de l'hebdo
politique très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]
les politiques